hello Katy nice to me electric you are
sunny
I love the new hair I know that it would
for the new music video right you should
talk to me about that and what you kind
of wanted to have in a bay with a new
music video yes contrary to public
assumption it's not this feminist
rebellion or even a statement of my
sexuality it's more so peeling away
every label fresh start and it's also an
act of mental health not
self-destruction I actually read your
entire article this week where you
really opened up about your struggles
and growing up in the industry so for
you to be here and celebrating young
Hollywood is it's nice because you're
using your platform what do you want
people to learn from your story well I
actually love that some of the media
that picked it up they were talking
about the actual diagnosis and going
into ways that we can help other people
empower themselves through those same
kind of transitions and medical mental
health issues so now I think the best
thing we can do tonight is celebrate
each other accept each other for exactly
who we are and hopefully talk about
maybe getting some mental health
practitioners on every set every tour to
help guide artists through the rough
period absolutely yeah
it's funny because I've interviewed many
young Hollywood stars and every single
one of them says there should be some
sort of counseling or onset therapy why
do you think we don't have that I don't
think people are necessarily looking out
for the humans I think we are brought up
to Studios first and foremost and we're
there to serve a greater purpose so the
thing is it would even have economic
value if labels knew that they could
rely on their artists to not be hungover
the next day and showing up and giving
their best performance so everyone wins
and of course it's humans first
everyone's help would win if we do that
how are you these days and what is the
key for you to stay healthy and to stay
balanced Louie to stay healthy
imbalanced I don't have a TV
I don't have a Netflix account I
meditate and a lot of it just has to do
with looking at what's happening in the
world and always seeing the bigger
picture
you know I'm working on my podcast and
just talking with experts and people who
have nothing to do with entertainment
and then using the art of storytelling
to just educate people and other things
happening the world is a lot bigger than
this because you have used such a story
you've gone through so much do you
regret getting into this industry at
such a young age in some ways I can only
move forward the best thing I can do
right now is to turn the pain into
something proactive that helps other
people so I'm working on above I'm
talking with therapists and counselors
about putting together a curriculum that
can help prepare young people who are
going through the same experiences if I
don't do that I feel like that's a major
disservice and it's also healing for me
to know that other people are taking
preventative measures interesting this
week Justin Bieber said that he is
getting treatment for depression and
he's been struggling I guess with Fame
we all know Demi Lovato's story have you
reached out to any of them or do you
have a message of hope maybe my message
of hope I think is just to first look
them in the eyes and and humanize each
other I think the hope will come
naturally when we first have the proper
break to breathe if we can't take an
inhalation and we can
all of the stress you're never gonna
find equilibrium and it's always going
to be a farce and you're gonna go into
treatment you're going to come out
you're going to go right back in so it's
about giving everyone the proper time
they need to develop holistically it's
not rocket science that we're all human
beings and it's not rocket science that
the system is set up to kind of bring
out the extremes in each other so I
think my message is always and when we
do talk with each other it's always to
just support support support and put our
well-being first in the equation and
career all of it will follow what was
the turning point for you when you
realize that you wanted to change that
maybe you needed some some help I was
about 18 years old and I had just gone
into treatment myself
and I was having hair loss seizures all
these health issues that were huge my
body was yelling at me right loud sirens
and I was under contracts that prevented
me from getting help and I asked myself
so what extent am I willing to sacrifice
my health for this work especially if
I'm trying to promote a positive image
if I was trying to promote disruption
and I was pacing it but I like to walk
the walk and and now just talk the talk
so I knew that I had to put integrity
first and I got help and then afterwards
I started leaking my own content and I
was like wait a second this is so
liberating so empowering and we can set
out some
because I have direct access to my
community now like studios all these
people they don't want us to know that
we have a lot of power so the more I use
my boys and the more I connect directly
my I think beautiful things are
happening what is 2019 look like for you
you have the podcast you have the book
what else like what does this year
really symbolize for you it's a shift
from treating life as a push to trusting
the intuitive decide so instead of just
seeing how far I can go before I burn
out it's a using this core as the
foundation for every decision creatively
artistically professionally personally
[Music]